This iron worker has made a successful career for herself.
I love physical work.
You may find Adrienne Donato 30 feet above the ground...
...welding and using a handheld jackhammer.
She even worked for the same company through two pregnancies.
They were very supportive.
Iron workers are just one of many fields now trying to recruit women.
The industry just announced the new paid maternity benefit.
They're gonna make good money but they're gonna have great benefits to go along with it...
...so they'll have that health insurance and a pension plan.
And the trucking industry says there's a shortage of drivers.
Driver Jody Edwards and the Women and Trucking Association is trying to change that.
They created a girl scout patch to show trucking isn't just for men.
And Jody is now part of her company's recruiting campaign.
They're trying to tap what is potentially an untapped field of employees,...
...and that's women.
They can come and have a normal day job and they can go home at night.
This training institute says the number of women...
...in its sheet metal apprenticeship program has doubled in two years.
And the Automotive Women's Alliance Foundation offers scholarships.
So, why the push for women in these industries and companies?
It's good to be able to show that they have a diverse workforce.
Whether that helps them to win business...
...or show legitimacy in the markets that they're serving.
Research shows gender diversity in the workplace...
...can lead to higher profits and productivity.